[MUSIC]
What?
Oh, FU?
That wasn't even there before.
Pass, no.
I refuse.
okay, check point.
F, aah.
Do, do, Oh, what the hell was that?
Bugger, bugger.
Come on.
[LAUGH]
I got a life to live.
This isn't fair to me.
[SOUND]
I, I might have a family some day.
Oh, God.
How do I even get past this one?
I don't even know.
[SOUND]
Oh, fuck.
Ha ha
[LAUGH].
[SOUND]
This isn't right.
Why do I have to go through these things
for your entertainment.
I didn't even.
>> Go back.
>> I didn't even touch it.
>> [LAUGH].
[LAUGH]
hawk.
[SOUND]
I'm okay.
Alright, I'm okay I just.
I did not know that was going to happen.
[SOUND]
Aah!
It's all one big booby trap.
Fuck you.
[MUSIC]
Awe, ball.
Aah!
[NOISE]
Ball.
Aah!
He wasn't even near it.
Yeah.
Aah!
[NOISE]
What?
Double?
What's the point of doing double?
Aah!
[NOISE]
Oh my god.
Ooh!
Wasn't even near it.
Aah!
[NOISE]
[SOUND]
Aah!
I knew it was going to be tricksies.
I am so angry.
I am frackie, turning French.
100th death.
[SOUND]
Yeah.
Aw.
[MUSIC]
huh, huh huh
[NOISE]
huh yeah, go over, oh I was going to go
over it.
Ahh, no, ahh, oh,
[SOUND]
splat.
Gah,
[MUSIC]
I'm uhh, okay, now drop.
Fuck.
Aah!
[NOISE]
[SOUND]
Well.
Aah!
Okay.
There's a big, open area here.
[MUSIC]
What's going on?
You son of a bitch.
[SOUND]
Whoa whoa.
Wawa I wasn't even near it.
[NOISE]
So much anger!
Aah, aah,
[NOISE]
aah, alright.
No, no, oh, fuck.
Oh, oh,
how was it, god.
[MUSIC]
Oh, oh, aah, fuck you.
Ohh, eh,
What, that was new.
They take our potatos,
[SOUND]
what the fucking hell, i am so close, i
got!
Continue with the bouncing strategy,
fudge.
[LAUGH]
[MUSIC]
You son of a bitch, that's a trap.
That's a trap.
draw, draw a trap.
Everything is a trap.
[MUSIC]
Fuck you, there is a trap!
[SOUND].
There's a trap.
[NOISE]
[MUSIC]
And, then, stay here, and then jump over,
and then jump.
[MUSIC]
And, fuck, I'm going to die.
You son of a bitch.
All right, I'm dead.
Ba boo ba da.
All right, I'm just going to jump for it.
[NOISE]
Well that was wrong.
Aah!
[NOISE]
Rableloo bey!
Aah Aah!
[NOISE]
Oh, no!
No.
[MUSIC]
[SOUND]
My life is filled with such pain.
[NOISE]
I wasn't even near him.
Is that going to be enough?
[MUSIC]
I don't care, here I go,
[NOISE]
oh, my god.
Oh, no.
God.
Get out of there Mario!
[LAUGH]
[SOUND]
Fucking hell.
Come on, Mario, do it.
No, don't, don't.
Did it!
[MUSIC]
Touch it, you stupid asshole.
No, go.
Stop with the music.
No!
[NOISE]
No.
I did it again Piss.
Why?
It was almost stuffed.
[SOUND]
Why is this going on?
[MUSIC]
Wow, that's a
[LAUGH]
...Okay, corner.
Oh.
Hump.
Bounce off the top.
[SOUND]
Fudge.
Oh, oh.
Ha ha
[LAUGH].
No.
Why Mario?
Stop greasing your feet.
[MUSIC]
This is what happens.
No
[NOISE].
Yay.
Well, what the tent's in Magoo.
Oh my god.
[MUSIC]
[LAUGH]
Yes.
Yes!
[MUSIC]
Oh God.
No.
Go live.
[COUGH]
No!
[LAUGH]
You bitch.
No!
[NOISE]
Noooo!
Oh, my God.
Please tell me.
[NOISE]
No.
It's hopeless.
My whole method.
I can't make that jump.
I was a mile off.
[MUSIC]
My whole life is a lie.
Everything I've done is meaningless.
[MUSIC]
Torn down like the pillars of society.
Aah!
[NOISE]
This has been the Unfair Mario
Compilation.
[MUSIC]
Thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed my pain and suffering and
want to see more, why not subscribe to my
channel.
[MUSIC]
want to help the channel grow.
Leave a like.
Add it to your favorites, or share it with
your friends on Facebook and Twitter.
Thanks again.
[MUSIC]
And as always, I will see you, in the next
video.
Buh bye
[MUSIC]